I mentioned the other day during our
story about chicken sandwiches at
Popeyes that it's been like 18 years
since I went to a fast food restaurant
here is a very specific question from a
viewer left by voicemail at two one nine
two david p about my fast food hiatus
take a listen
hey David you mentioned that you haven't
had any fast food ten or fifteen years I
wanted to know if you would consider
fast casual food like jakoli or five
guys press City maybe be good as fast
food or you know do you partake in those
when you're dieting out and in hurry
thanks Mike we'll listen it's not it's
it has a name it's fast casual again is
that a corporate a focus group name fast
casual instead of fast food makes it
sound better in some way i I don't I
don't go to those places either I go to
I'm trying to think when I flew through
I believe it's Washington Dulles there's
like I think in the international
terminal at least last time I was there
there was nothing other than a Chipotle
so I did get a grilled chicken burrito
at Chipotle that was probably eight
years ago but no I I just don't go to
any of those places I'm lucky enough to
live in places and mostly be in places
big cities and also kind of like
hipstery small towns you know Portland
Maine Burlington Vermont Western
Massachusetts LA San Francisco Boston
Miami these are all places where you
just never need to go to any of these
chains usually usually there are just
local options that are much better so no
I don't really go to the fast casual
places I don't really go to any of them
unless it is an emergency although
actually here's a story when I was
flying back from Aruba last week the
Aruban Airport is a disaster I think it
took nearly two hours of just going
through different lines to finally get
to my gate and the only thing available
in the international gate area where I
was waiting was a Sbarro so I went to
Sbarro and got a slice of pizza and it
was vile I mean just absolutely vile so
anyway now I avoid the entire thing
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show fantastic bonus show coming
up for you today